this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by skillshare
home to thousands of classes that could
teach you a new life skill
over the past decade wind energy has
seen astronomical growth
rising from a worldwide total of 24.3
megawatts in 2001
to 650 000 megawatts in 2019
concerns in the 90s that wind energy
could not be integrated
into the grid reliably have all but
vanished as we learned
how to adapt our grids to handle the
fluctuations in the wind
with the right climate infrastructure
and policy
wind can form a substantial percentage
of a country's
energy generation we need to look no
further
than denmark to see the proof of this
in 2019 denmark sourced 47
of its electricity generation from wind
power that wasn't a single day
that was the year-round average on one
particularly windy day denmark
actually produced 140 percent of its
electricity needs
with wind energy and thanks to robust
interconnections
with its neighboring countries denmark
was able to sell
the vast majority of that generation to
norway
germany and sweden denmark is ideally
located to benefit from wind power
but its closest rival in europe ireland
is isolated in the middle of the
atlantic with relatively primitive
interconnection
to the uk and only one pumped hydro
station in the entire country
yet ireland managed to generate 32.5
percent of its power
from wind in 2019 grid operators are
learning how
to reliably integrate wind energy into
the energy market place
where energy is bought and sold almost
like the stock market
in countries like denmark it has evolved
rapidly to adapt to wind energy
becoming faster and more responsive
using weather predictions to schedule
and dispatch
other power sources as needed i would be
amazed to not mention the importance of
natural gas
in this equation a fast and responsive
form of fossil fuel power
that can quickly ramp up to supply power
when winds die down
natural gas is an unsung hero in this
story
and won't be going anywhere until we
develop cheap and scalable energy
storage solutions
but it's undeniable the inertia is with
wind power
now and with offshore wind becoming
cheaper and more attractive
it will only grow stronger countries
around the world
are investing billions into wind energy
technology
and one fascinating trend has emerged
over the past two decades
wind turbines keep getting bigger the
average wind turbine height
and diameter has continually risen
during that time
in the early 1990s the average wind
turbine was about
27 meters in diameter but year on year
the average wind turbine has grown in
diameter
continually pushing the limit of what
was possible
continually increasing the power the
turbine was capable of generating
continually driving down the cost of
electricity as the literal economies of
scale
kicked in you see the power a wind
turbine can generate
is dependent on its ability to convert
kinetic energy
from the wind into electricity so we can
derive a
very simple formula to calculate how
much power a wind turbine can generate
if it was 100 deficient by starting with
the equation for kinetic energy
we don't want energy we want power which
is energy per unit time
so we need to swap out this mass
variable for a variable that defines
how much mass passes through the
circular area
swept by a wind turbine per unit time
for that we need the area of the circle
the velocity of the air passing through
that area
and the density of the air if we swap
these in
we now have an equation that defines the
power a 100 percent efficient wind
turbine
could extract from the wind with this
equation we get a simple answer for why
wind turbines keep getting bigger
the area figure is determined by the
radius squared
by doubling the wind turbine blade
radius which has been happening
roughly every 10 years we are
quadrupling the maximum power the wind
turbine can generate
and with that the cost of electricity
for these turbines
also plummets but how big can they get
in 2019 a prototype version of the most
powerful wind turbine was installed
in rotterdam this massive 220 meter
diameter wind turbine
stands 260 meters tall measured up
against the eiffel tower
a city-dominating landmark it would
stand at about 80 percent of its height
but this isn't a static structure it's
an incredibly powerful dynamic machine
a single rotation of its blades is so
powerful
that it could keep the average uk home
supplied
with electricity for two days
manufacturing these blades is
no easy task requiring incredibly
expensive specialized tooling
lm wind power which was acquired by ge
in 2019
manufactured the blades themselves and
have had
decades of experience in pushing the
boundaries in what is possible
it starts by manufacturing two massive
molds
that will form the shape of the blades
this itself
is a huge engineering challenge and
requires a huge amount of capital
investment molds require precise
machining
even small molds can be extremely
expensive
but these blades dwarf even the span of
an a380
the mold needs to be capable of drawing
a vacuum
to squeeze all the layers of glass fiber
together
and push out air as the plastic resin is
injected
and needs to be able to apply heat to
cure the resin too
these are unique expensive pieces of
tooling
that drive up the capital costs of wind
turbine blades
general electric made a great decision
in acquiring
lm wind power the company has
manufactured
228 000 wind turbine blades
since 1978. in that time
they've broken numerous records
including the record for the delivery of
the longest piece of cargo in history
when they commissioned the biggest plane
on earth the antonov an-255
to carry two 42 meter wind turbine
blades
from their manufacturing facility in
china to their testing facility
in denmark and that is often the
limiting factor in how large wind
turbines can be
there is currently no technology that
allows turbine blades
to be separated into smaller modular
sections
that can be assembled on site the blade
has to be transported as one solid piece
and lifted into place by specialized
cranes in the case of the halide x
the 107 meter long blades had to be
lifted
150 meters into the air by two
monstrously large cranes there is a
reason
offshore wind farms have the largest
wind turbines
it's much easier to build a wind turbine
factory directly next to a harbour
as lm wind has done in normandy for the
haliad
x blades and load them directly onto
massive ships capable of hauling them
directly to the wind farm location
trying to transport blades
this size on winding roads and railways
full of obstacles would be incredibly
challenging
and expensive if not just impossible in
most cases
transport and assembly costs which
require specialized boats
tooling and cranes to be purchased also
decreases the cost advantage of building
bigger
this is all before getting to the design
challenges
as the blades get longer the forces on
the structure grow too
the longer the blade the faster the tip
of the blade will be traveling
being zero at the rotational center and
increasing
with the distance from the center of
rotation longer blades will have
higher tip velocities than shorter
blades
even if they have the same rotational
speed
this is a problem the faster the tip
speed the louder the noise
and this is actually the primary factor
that limits the maximum
allowable tip velocities to get around
this
larger turbines are designed to rotate
slower
but with a higher torque that higher
torque requires a larger
and heavier drive shaft capable of
transmitting the torque
to a larger and heavier gearbox capable
of converting high torque
low speed rotation into the lower torque
higher speed rotation
needed for the generator the increased
complexity
needed to deal with this higher torque
results in a heavier
and more expensive drivetrain which
again reduces the cost advantage
of the greater power generation but
design problems
don't stop there the next issue are the
lateral forces the wind in parts on the
wind turbine
the tower and its foundations need to be
strong enough to resist the force of the
wind
that is attempting to tip it over this
force increases
with the increased area of the blades
and the blades also need to be stiff
enough
to resist the bending forces they
experience
the longer the blade the stiffer it
needs to be
to avoid the blade bending so far that
it strikes the tower
this is a major worry when stormy
conditions are
unavoidable some designers have proposed
collapsible blades
that rotate the nacelle so the blades
have their backs
to the wind and collapse like the
branches of a palm tree
in a hurricane this seems like
over-engineering to me though and just
introduces
too much complexity and potential sites
for failure
we may be reaching the limit of what we
can achieve with glass fiber reinforced
plastics
for blades as large as the halide x the
heavier blade
increases the centrifugal force
attempting to
yeast the entire structure apart the
slower rotational speeds help mitigate
this
but it is imperative to minimize the
weight of the blades
to reduce the forces attempting to rip
the blades off the hub
if wind turbine blades keep growing
manufacturers may have to consider
making the switch to carbon fiber
reinforced plastics
but this for now is prohibitively
expensive
our goal after all is to reduce the cost
of electricity
these complex and interlinked design
constraints have resulted
in a slow but steady increase in wind
turbine diameters
as better and cheaper drive trains
become available
as aerodynamic optimizations reduce
blade noise
as materials and manufacturing
techniques improve to reduce waste
allowing for larger and larger wind
turbines to be cost
effectively designed manufactured
transported
and assembled ultimately reducing the
levelized cost of electricity
of wind power to the point that coal
power stations are thankfully
becoming an archaic relic of the past
and during the writing of this episode
this record-breaking hallyat x
wind turbine was announced for use in
the massive offshore wind farm off the
coast of cape cod
as offshore wind becomes cheaper and
cheaper our ability to generate
clean energy is going to skyrocket we
are slowly learning how to make the most
of the resources
we have at our disposal here on earth
and to do it
sustainably which has been something i
have been learning while growing the
business
surrounding this youtube channel we are
managing to run
three channels with just four full-time
staff and to do that
we all have to constantly learn and
improve this year we made
radical changes to our task management
system and communication methods
and we were helped along with the advice
of my friend thomas frank
who has a fantastic productivity class
on skillshare
called productivity masterclass create a
custom system that works
which will help you create a task
management system
that you will actually keep up we have
also put a huge amount of effort into
improving our 3d animations in blender
and cinema 4d and you witness some of
the fruits of these learnings
in this video skillshare also has
fantastic courses on multiple animation
platforms
2d animation is actually an easy skill
to learn
i thought myself how to animate over a
single long weekend for the first video
on this channel
you just need to take the time to learn
lifelong learning
is a mandatory for anyone trying to
succeed in this world
and no matter what you are trying to
learn skillshare likely has a class to
teach you
with new years coming up there is no
better time to set yourself
a new skill to learn skillshare is an
online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious people
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no distracting ads
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
but the first 1000 people to sign up
with the link in the description
we'll get a free trial of skillshare
premium so there is no monetary risk in
trying it out and looking for a class
that piques your interest
before the trial ends if you are looking
for something else to watch right now
why not watch my previous video about
our efforts to create
renewable cargo ships or real sciences
latest video
detailing the strange blue blood of
horseshoe crabs
which has an incredibly important role
in modern day medicine
you